finish your bisque and put away your
snake you kinky bastards because it's
episode 3 of American Horror Story and I
think I just [ __ ] my pants the episode
begins with hot seitan finishing his
interviews to determine who is worthy of
being admitted to sanctuary
he says he's responsible for the seeds
which will save mankind and tells ghulam
timmy and mallory that they will be
saved
ghulam feels sorry for killing his Nana
but Langdon tells him she died
peacefully in her sleep then again you
can never really trust the spawn of
Satan he tells them that he has a power
called night vision of the soul in which
he can look into the places people want
to keep hidden
Mallory looking more and more like a kid
from Whoville is also interviewed by
Langdon even though she's a grey Langdon
can sense she wants to slit Coco's
throat for how she's been treated by her
he's also surprised to see Deana Stevens
there apparently they have a history she
says she's not powerful enough to stop
whatever it is he has planned does he
know that she is somehow related to the
witches and if so why would he want her
to join sanctuary
he says you're exactly the type of soul
I'm looking for to build my new world
he's not saving them he needs their
souls we'll get into more of that in a
bit
we learned that Andre is Dina's son and
that he thinks his mother is evil even
though it was likely her who paid for
him and his boyfriend for their outpost
tickets Langdon tells Mallory that the
rules of the old world the rules that
were honored in the breach are over this
line the breach is super interesting
because it hints at a war between the
forces of hell and either angels or
witches but now since the world has been
decimated new rules and new conflicts
between those forces will surely arise
he tells her that he wants people that
will not only taste from the forbidden
fruit but cut the [ __ ] tree down
forbidden fruit being the name of this
episode and a reference to the story of
Adam and Eve the snake and apple imagery
making it even more evident
Mallory tells Langdon that it feels like
someone is inside her wanting to claw
its way out she tries to leave when he
stops her but she unleashes a power so
fearsome that it jettisons him across
the room he retaliates by showing his
true form an old
man perhaps some sort of demon or even
his father Satan manifesting itself
through him for a brief moment Malory
retaliates again exploding the fireplace
igniting the room in a fireball much to
langdon surprise this is the first time
all season Langdon loses his composure
he no longer is his usual calm self
rather surprise
not having the answers he asks her who
are you and judging by her look she
doesn't know either
Langdon performs a satanic ritual
similar to the Wankel all saw him do in
his dreams in Episode two
he asked for power from his father who
is likely the Lord of Hell Satan he
tells him that he thought he destroyed
them all but one survived were led to
believe he's talking about witches but
by the end of the episode we know many
of them are still alive and with him
knowing Dena was one of them is Mallory
something different not a witch but an
angel she even says to Langdon I have no
dark places an angel would be the most
logical this season providing a great
foil to the Satanism of Michael Landon
and the cooperative as he continues the
ritual the blood begins to boil and
snakes emerge looks like they didn't
come from the pipes or ventilation
shafts like Mead guessed in Episode two
something takes over Langdon his eyes
turned jet black and he says the words
Ave Satanas which is Latin for hail seen
in a series of kick-ass flashbacks we
follow young Meade on Halloween dressed
coincidentally like a robot at her first
stop she's given guess what a forbidden
fruit fast forward to her first date
watching Rosemary's Baby a movie about a
pregnant woman giving birth to the devil
there's even a dude wearing devil horns
in the back fast forward again to her
first kill as an agent for Mossad the
International Intelligence Agency for
Israel Halloween seems to bring back her
memories and if we remember from the
dates on the emails in episode 2
Halloween is just around the corner we
find Meade is talking to venable letting
her know about her being a robot
questioning if all of her memories were
simply programmed she recollects one
memory in particular of taking care of a
little blond boy but the memory is such
a blur is she referring to young Michael
Dhin from season ones murder house
Venable tells her Langdon can't be
trusted to take the right people to
sanctuary and when Mead finds out
Venable wasn't chosen to go they concoct
a plan kill them all
steal his computer and find out where
sanctuary is we're finally going topside
where the pus and blister filled
cannibals are having a beach party and
look who it is from episode one Coco's
boyfriend Brock but something tells me
she's not going to approve of his
makeover he asked him if they've heard
of a bunker for the rich when he's
ambushed and fights them off his shotgun
making quick work of them a carriage
similar to the one Langdon came in an
episode one rushes away but it can't be
Langdon since his horses were eaten at
the end of that episode it must be from
someone else in the cooperative an alarm
goes off a learning Venable of a
perimeter breach
it's the carriage and inside is a box
but underneath Brock hides using the
carriage like a Trojan horse in the
decontamination chamber the box is
checked for radioactivity and is deemed
clean inside are dozens of apples
Venable thinks Langdon sent them to
prove to the survivors what will be
waiting for them in sanctuary she orders
the fist to take care of the horses
while Meade offers a solution to their
Langdon problem hold a party and offer
the poison apples as a gift killing
every last person in outpost 3 before
taking care of Langdon remember it was
when Eve ate from the forbidden fruit
that she and Adam were banished from the
Garden of Eden and lost eternal life
topside Brock stabs the fist stealing
her key card to gain access to the
outpost
Mallory stares at the fire question who
she really is as dissonant violin chords
play similar to those found in the
shining Venable calls an emergency
meeting to announce their Victorian ball
themed Halloween party with all they've
been through they deserve a time to
relax and let loose their long toes
Coco's hair in what has to be one of the
most outrageous hairstyles I've ever
seen
when Mallory asked if she can use Coco's
lubes Louis Vuitton's to make a mask and
if you know Coco you know that ain't a
go-go
she thinks the party's where they'll
nounce who gets chosen for sanctuary and
no way in hell is Mallory going to get
chosen
Mallory tells them how she made the fire
explode in Langdon's office kind of like
the Dark Phoenix a reference to the
x-men character Jean Grey who has
powers KOCO borates Mallory telling her
to prove it right there [ __ ] but
Mallory can't seem to harness her power
the party has begun and Mead brings in
the forbidden fruit so that everyone can
Bob for apples a nod to season one and
Zachary Quintos character who prepared
bobbing for apples on Halloween in the
murder house Venable explains the
importance of All Hallows Eve when the
boundary between this world and the
other thins coincidentally also the time
when the boundary between the outpost
and the outside world thins bonus points
if you saw Timmy's vest with the patches
Koko dances with who she thinks is
Langdon explaining how marvellous it
will be when she's taken to sanctuary as
a gesture of goodwill she offers to give
him something she never gave her
boyfriend she brings him back to her
room and sorry we don't get to see his
radioactive penis Brock reveals himself
and Koko feigns happiness saying how
she's so glad to see him again but he's
not having it and stabs her in the face
Mead can't seem to find Koko or the fist
anywhere and suggest a Venable that they
stop their plan there's too many
witnesses Venable says they must go
forward and we learned they used the
snake venom to concoct their poison she
makes a toast to good fortune and
everyone eats before were treated to the
American Horror Story equivalent of the
red wedding the denizens of outpost 3
convulsive vomiting up blood and bits of
apple til every last one of them is dead
worst party ever
Venable and Mead inspect the dead
reveling in their victory before heading
off to Langdon at gunpoint they tell
Langdon they're making the selections
now and in a cruel twist of malice
Langdon tells her that she passed
she'll be accepted to sanctuary she
instructs me to shoot but Mead suddenly
turns the gun and Venable is killed
Meads been under Langdon's control the
whole time not only that he was the one
who came up with a poison apple plan we
learned she was made by the cooperative
research and development department a
prototype of a woman who took care of
Langdon as a child Langdon is the blonde
hair boy she referenced earlier in the
episode but who is she modelled on the
prevailing theory at the moment is she's
based off Jessica Lange's character
Constance from season one
the woman we see here taking care of
young Michael
Langdon then were treated to the best
part of the series so far the return of
the witches Cordelia good Myrtle snow
and Madison Montgomery
Cordelia breeze life into what she calls
their sisters Coco Mallory and Deana
resurrecting them before Madison tells
Mallory surprise [ __ ] I bet you thought
you'd seen the last of me but the
question remains how does Madison know
Mallory and is it connected to that
thing inside her clawing to get out is
it Zoe from season three potentially
alluding to the spirits of misty and
Queenie in the bodies of Coco and Deana
or is it something else entirely Madison
isn't referring to Mallory herself but
the thing inside her the angel notice
also how Mallory took off her glasses
after being resurrected seemingly curing
her vision problems if you recall from
season three after Madison was
resurrected it cured her of her heart
murmur and what will happen to the
others surely this isn't the last we'll
see of ghulam my guess is that since
this was all part of Michaels plan he
now has access to their souls so we
shouldn't count out that he'll be doing
some resurrecting of his own but this
also calls into question the other
bunkers were they overrun like Langdon
and Venable said or were their souls
taken by him
if the bunker they're in used to be in
all-boys schools if possible the
co-operative is tied to the warlocks
male practitioners of evil magic this
would provide a foil to the all-girls
witches coven in season three so are we
looking at a battle between witches and
the powers of hell or that of angels and
demons
perhaps some combination of both we'll
just have to tune in next week to find
out hey everyone I hope you liked this
video as always I hope you'll like
subscribe share all that fun stuff and
check out my other videos and don't
forget daddy loves you very much